caleb how you doing buddy oh uh i'm
doing pretty good actually i'm having a
good night how are y'all good man so
what's your question for us uh so
i see a lot of you or y'all uh the high
value man i mean um
they have skills and almost um what was
the habits
that uh a lot of other people just don't
have and i was wondering
about as far as building habits and
skills uh what would you all focus on as
a high value now
i would say discipline's probably the
number one
uh gumption and probably discipline what
would you guys say
dummy discipline is absolutely mission
critical um but also let's say right
it's you have to have an objective so
depending on what direction you want to
go those are the habits you want to
focus on right so i mean if you're going
more down the fitness and
route then you have a specific plan for
hey i want to get really big or i want
to get really lean or hey i want to run
really fast really high so know kind of
what your mission objective is so that
way you can kind of formulate some
taylor specific habits because there's
going to be very good general habits
that you can have but if you really want
to separate yourself and you really want
to get to the top or the peak of
anything you're going to have to
specialize so specialize in some
particular set of habits for your end
objective that would be the way that um
i would go about approaching habits you
know what i look for like like honestly
if i'm if i'm interviewing somebody
i mean i'm just gonna say it like i look
at their physical state
if they're out of shape if they're obese
like if they're not physically fit
then it's pretty much an automatic
dismissal for me like if you don't have
the discipline
to sleep work out and eat properly why
would you do a good job for me
i agree you see what i'm saying
yup workout is one thing i will add
though
one of the greatest tests of
self-discipline for a man is when you're
at a night venue like in a bar
and you see a very attractive woman
you're attracted to but then her
boyfriend comes along and puts her his
hand on her back
and then you know it's over
do you look back at her again do you
look in that direction again if you do
that you have no self-discipline you
just wasted a second in your life
right i've uh yeah i've definitely
really uh started cracking down and
chilling like that lately like
not rejecting myself before somebody
else rejects me type stuff like that uh
so and watching you all
you have definitely helped me build that
discipline and stuff so you should only
get the people who like you back in the
end of the day that's a kind of
self-discipline i have that role only
like spend time with people that like
you back right yeah all my friends like
me it's crazy um i have one surprise egg
we love you jared
i realized that until the miami trip i
was like well i have like 30 friends now
like i don't have 30 friends at any
point in my life this is amazing um
another one that i always say to guys to
especially i'm at the point in my career
where younger guys are asking me for
advice i'm like wait i don't have any
mentors so that's a big reason i got
rich's group too but one thing i would
tell young guys is a curiosity too so
you know something needs to be done um a
renegade wingman set a good one
objective so like for example when i
lost like 100 pounds years ago i knew i
had i knew i had to lose the weight it
was it was literally physically holding
me back um rich i agree with you because
i've been obese and i've been 10 body
fat and i've maintained i'm probably
like 10 12 all times all year round
figure out how to maintain it uh your
mind is different too my mind is sharp
when i'm in shape my mind is my mind is
on when i'm out of shape usually when
you're eating crap you're drinking too
you're not sleeping well like your mind
is just slush
i call it slop and rich's form i was
like hey if you're eating slop you're
going to think like slop you're going to
look like slop but um getting back to
the main point is curiosity so i knew
for example i had to go down this
fitness journey i didn't i didn't know i
was going to end where i where i'm at
and very i actually surprised myself to
this day every day i look in the mirror
i'm like wow i would have never imagined
this 15 years ago but have that element
of curiosity in that in being that you
don't know all the answers a lot of guys
get real dogmatic in the red pill space
about red philosophy in their fitness
like i'm a vegan i'm a crossfitter i'm a
carnivore i'm this or that try it all
take the elements that work for you and
then put it together in your own
framework and then stick to it um and
then consistency goes in handheld
discipline um
it's great i know a lot of guys like i'm
going to get started on this fitness
goal i'm going to cut out all these
things i'm going to make these wild
radical changes in my cage just
just just cut out just cut out like one
crappy meal a week first or just you
know start slow or just get to the gym
just get in the habit of going there
first because if you do too much at once
you're going to burn yourself out your
your body's not going to be able to
handle it and you're going to set
yourself up for failure so i'd say
curiosity and consistency
i'd say that's one of the best pieces of
advice that you could give anyone in
that like should be clipped right there
is really the best habit you can have is
make it your own because so many guys
get caught up in trying to like be
carbon copies of someone else and they
that leads to that burnout or that
frustration or whatever so really it is
a phenomenal like that easy
i'm going to clip that and just start
showing it some of my clients right now
um
thank you for the advice yeah and caleb
just you know like last thing a lot of
guys make um like very
um
small plans you know like they have
basic disciplinary sort of plans like no
fap like
congratulations you didn't touch your pp
for a day you know well done it's like
you know make someone like dead you know
like you're thinking you might as well
think big right
think big thanks buddy
you